hello everyone my name is bradley and
today there are a couple of uninvited
guests on our tour through the online
jungle i'm talking about these two
smartphones we've got apple's very own
iphone x this is my personal iphone and
then we've got
xiaomi's redmi now i'm sure you've
wondered maybe once or twice are these
phones actually listening in to our
conversations because one moment you
might be talking to your mate on the
phone about your love for kylie minogue
[Music]
and then the next day we're getting
contextual advertising offering you her
merchandise right this happened to us
all for instance if you were discussing
a picnic well get ready to see barbecue
girls offered to you and if you're
planning to go skiing well good luck
escaping from the ads for resorts and
their restaurants
is it just a coincidence or are
smartphones really eavesdropping on us
well today we're going to jump into
exactly this
[Music]
so we're going to start off by
conducting a simple experiment yesterday
i asked my colleague to bring me a
travel guide from a country that i
haven't yet been to i planned to open it
on a random page and then choose a
random word that i've never heard of or
used before right now here's the book
the dutch i presume right
and i actually opened it on page 82 and
i found this very interesting word um
vlafflip so we've got a little bit of
text here the dutch awoke one day to the
fla flip a combination of yogurt vanilla
flour and lemon syrup right sounds
delicious i've never heard of this
before but vlaffip would flat flip would
be a really good word to use here it
immediately catches the eye
i'm going to put both phones out in
front of me i'm going to say out loud a
few key phrases that should provoke the
appearance of ads for flaffip itself
right these could be websites or recipes
or dutch cuisine restaurants if they
exist in london of course so let's start
[Music]
i've always dreamed of trying vlaffip
because i love desserts in yogurts i
don't know if it's possible to buy
vlaffett in london oh if only i could
make vlaffip by myself at home all i
need is a vlaffip recipe a little yogurt
lemon and custard the vlafip will soon
be ready i love laughing i want to buy
indeed vladhip right now
[Music]
vladimir
so look guys um if smartphones are
really listening in on what we're saying
i should really be seeing some kind of
advertisements on my facebook now but
there's nothing really like that as of
yet
so maybe we should wait some time for
the next couple of hours while i'm
shooting this video i'm going to mention
blaffip again and again and again and
see if the phones pick anything up so as
we're filming and saying this word
vlaffip over and over again these two
pocket spies may be listening in and
noting my interest in trying flaffip in
london so this is a good way to figure
out whether these suspicions are
justified in principle
[Music]
anyway the first conversations about
smartphone eavesdropping emerged really
with the emergence of smartphones
themselves of course for the first time
ever in history we all began to
constantly walk around the planet with a
microphone and a radio transmitter in
our pockets we also tend to make sure
that these devices are constantly
charged
however until 2011 this topic was mainly
discussed by fans of conspiracy theories
in terms of persuasiveness it was
akin to the level of rumors that the us
government was monitoring the movement
of hundred dollar bills from satellites
right they're watching us but everything
changed in 2011 when cook announced a
voice assistant called siri with the
presentation of the new iphone 4s
siri
is your intelligent assistant
that helps you get things done
just by asking hey there siri what's a
guy gotta do to find night crawlers nash
wobbin on dialing 9-1-1 you were having
a stroke no no no no it seemed to be a
miracle that the smartphone can really
understand and execute complex commands
siri could even write an sms via
dictation and send it to the relevant
person however it was not without its
technical overlaps for example using
siri with a 4s you could send sms's even
from a locked phone
well that weighty took highwest pictures
of my junk last night for quakes west
it wasn't even necessary to press the
home button siri just responded to its
name and sometimes siri accidentally
switched on when you said something that
sounded like siri we still get this
problem nowadays of course
then came the suspicions that
smartphones were constantly recording
what we're saying and therefore are
constantly eavesdropping on us moreover
they're sending all of that information
straight to cupertino where apple is
headquartered in fact this is very far
from the truth siri on your phone or
tablet is dumber than a canary the only
thing she can understand is her name and
she only really starts recording after
that
now your commander request is sent to
apple's cloud services because it needs
to be processed by powerful computers
[Music]
and that means that even if you ask your
phone to do something really simple
changing the volume or changing say the
brightness then the command will come
from apple's server this method was
chosen to the fact that the phone's on
board resources were not powerful enough
for voice recognition you know it is
hard right and your iphone is old now
all of this can be visualized if we
analyze the amount of data that the
phone exchanges with the network look
i'm going to turn off my mobile internet
right and connect to my wi-fi router
instead and then i'm going to take my
laptop where i'm going to run a program
that will monitor how my phone is
communicating with the outside world now
look there's almost no traffic right now
but as soon as i say
hey siri
how many calories in a pizza
a package of pizza has about 1
948 calories my smartphone transmits a
recording of my question to apple's
server and then receives a ready-made
answer
by the way guys i'll just note here i
specifically did not mention lafip in
the request siri is looking for unders
on the internet through basically the
same search engines as us and therefore
google can understand that i'm
interested in dutch dessert and this
will probably disrupt the cleanliness of
the experiment now interestingly siri
couldn't work without the internet until
september of this year with ios 15 it's
now able to execute simple commands
without internet connection but don't
get excited just yet sure it will set
your alarm for you without internet
connection but it won't be able to even
perform basic calculations
now it's not just the computing power
that's the problem here but also the
amount of memory that's required to
store all of these neural links in
siri's machine learning model it's just
very resource intensive
[Music]
now the google voice assistant in
smartphones televisions and speakers
works on exactly the same principle ok
google how many calories in a pizza
now the device records requests and
sends them to google servers for
processing just like siri does so look
what if it's not just about individual
requests what prevents mobile phones or
smart speakers from transmitting all of
our conversations to their creators
first of all this would greatly increase
network traffic from such devices one
simple question to siri over a couple of
seconds leads to little more than 60
kilobytes of traffic not much right well
one minute will take around two
megabytes and over the course of an hour
more than a hundred megabytes are
transferred and over the course of one
day it's likely that we'll spend much
longer than one hour talking to people
not only that but the device will not be
able to filter out extraneous sounds for
example dialogues in the cinema or news
releases on the radio in the taxi on the
way to work i mean in this case they
also need to be recorded and transmitted
and it would be really difficult to hide
such a volume of traffic right even if
the manufacturer hid these statistics on
your phone itself you'd notice the
increased costs on your phone bill at
the end of the month surely and if
you're still not convinced you could
plant a traffic monitoring program on
your smartphone and with that help it's
easy to determine who really transmits
the data to who in addition thousands of
enthusiasts around the world like to
analyze the network activity of new
devices and network administrators in
large companies would also quickly
notice suspicious traffic on their wi-fi
routers and gateways i am so suspicious
do you remember the story of the launch
of the home mini
well in 2017 it was google's most
affordable smart speaker before the
start of official sales a small batch of
pre-production devices were basically
sent to journalists and bloggers for the
purposes of first tests and reviews now
almost immediately it turned out that on
some devices the voice assistant power
button sticks
the speaker starts continuously
recording everything and sending
everything it hears to google then the
mics off the mics off the mic's off the
mic this error appeared only on a few
devices but it did not go unnoticed to
avoid serious accusations of espionage
google urgently released a firmware that
disabled said sticky button
by the way if you're using devices that
feature this google assistant you can
view an entire history of requests on
your profile page
it's thanks to this that journalists
from android police discovered the
suspicious activity of the smart speaker
you see here are the questions i asked
google while i was preparing the script
for this video
how smartphones you've dropped on us how
to protect yourself from wiretapping how
siri works and even the question of the
calorie content of pizza however
notably there's not a single word about
the dutch vlaflip in addition recording
and transmitting all conversations is a
really resource intensive task the
additional load on the processor and
communication modules on your phone
would be manifested by the phone heating
up rapidly and there would be a
noticeable battery discharge these same
signs are able to give away the activity
of say malicious programs like
cryptocurrency miners or botnets and if
you notice such behavior on your i would
say android smartphone i recommend
installing antivirus software and also
checking the device regularly and
thoroughly
and finally recording conversations and
imperceptibly transmitting them into a
cloud service is a very difficult task i
mean it's doable in principle but
difficult
when you do this everything becomes so
much more complex to extract even a
little bit of useful information from
our chatter we would first have to turn
speech into text
simple well not really
recognition algorithms are complex and
again resource intensive and the results
are far from ideal for example switch on
automatic subtitles on youtube
the recognition program often can't even
cope with studio recorded sound and i
really doubt it's going to be able to
breeze through and decipher some pocket
dial style nonsense right
so what can we say about the recordings
that can be obtained from a smartphone
well this is exactly how the smartphone
hears me and this is lying right there
right do you really think youtube would
be able to handle the word vladflip
well rewind to the recording click on
the subtitles icon and see for yourself
big companies are big because they focus
on making money so
why on earth would they want to spend
loads of resources on developing complex
and not entirely legitimate
eavesdropping systems when especially
they already know more about us than we
can possibly imagine
[Music]
in the video we did about information
bubbles and advertising algorithms i
described in detail how our search
queries and behavior on social networks
form our virtual image everything we've
read searched liked and reposted is
added to your digital dossier and
companies also collect information about
our movements right our physical
activity they determine deviations from
our usual daily routine and they even
know how to read email subject headings
based on all of this data a detailed
consumer model of each network user is
built and the more data there is about
each of us and about our environment
then the more efficiently this whole
system works former google ethicist
tristan harris compared a digital
profile to a small voodoo doll all i
have to do is simulate what conversation
the video doll is having and i know the
conversation you just had without having
to listen to the microphone
okay let's take a quick look at my phone
because i just got a notification and it
says it's dinner time right and how does
it know this well
in recent years from 6 p.m to 8 p.m most
days i tend to search for or check into
restaurants now i went for run in the
morning and then spent most of the day
recording this video and a few minutes
ago remember i was looking for the data
on the calorie content of pizza so now
you understand why on google there's an
advertisement for a nearby italian
restaurant and that's appeared right now
regardless nothing dutch or yogurt-based
disappeared on the screen and it seems
that neither google nor apple have found
out anything about my desire or interest
in flafflip
or maybe they need more time right i
mean while the recording is decrypted
processed and data is added to the
profile so let's continue with the video
now importantly it's the effectiveness
of conceptual advertising just created
this myth about the wiretapping of our
smartphones there's always a reason
right why we get advertising it doesn't
arise by itself right they always have a
starting point ultimately someone will
see something interesting on the
internet they'll read an article or a
post they'll search for details and all
of that remains in google's memory now
this is known as active interest which
is a great reason to show contextual
advertising and not just to one person
but to their friends to their colleagues
or family members and such groups of
people are called the domain of users
and targeting them is one of the most
effective methods of advertising to date
and also of course our brain loves to
look for coincidences while discarding
everything else i mean do you know how
many ads are around you every single day
well every day you see from six to ten
thousand ads and of course we forget
almost all of them straight away let me
think about it if you don't need tractor
wheels an engagement ring or a
collector's edition of zelda then you're
really unlikely to remember that those
things are actually advertised to you
but you'll surely pay attention to that
banner you saw associated with a recent
conversation and you'll remember that
particular case
such selective coincidences are the
third component of the myth of the
omniscient orwellian google
[Music]
now there is one question that remains
can you delete your voice data yes you
can and as an example i'm going to show
you how to delete your recorded voice
remarks on your iphone but you'll
remember if you have more than one apple
product then you'll need to repeat a
similar process on every apple device
that you own now we're going to do is
delete all of the information apple gets
from siri including recordings of your
voice but the way to do that isn't
through visit your privacy settings
instead do this go to settings
siri and search
then turn off all the ways that siri can
be activated and there are two listen
for hey siri and press the side button
for siri when you turn off the last way
to activate siri that effectively
switches siri off and then you'll get a
warning that there is one more step you
need to do to delete your data from
apple's servers
go to settings
general then keyboard and scroll down to
where you see enable dictation when you
tick it off you're done
[Music]
right hello everyone it's been one week
and i've been checking daily to see what
kind of advertisements appear in my
social media and what do you think a i
received lots of advertising for
vladflip b i received advertising for
dessert but not specifically blafflip or
c i received none of the above nothing
out of the ordinary what do you reckon
well if you suggested c you were totally
correct because i received nothing out
of the ordinary certainly no dutch
dessert for that matter so i think we
can say with all certainty that our
smartphones are not listening into our
conversations
but having said that i did spend a lot
more time than usual studying the sort
of advertisements that i was getting and
i found a lot of advertising for
antivirus software for smartphones now
that's because i was actually searching
how to hack smartphones spoiler alert
from maybe a future new video um and i
also got a lot of advertising for
discounts from thin air and this is
probably because i changed my flights
last week but really nothing out of the
ordinary so
no vladflip
[Music]
we're ultimately afraid of what we don't
understand big data processing
algorithms cluster analysis variable
segmentation digital profiles i mean all
of this sounds too complicated to really
grasp and therefore we like to accept a
simple explanation
we are being overheard
and i immediately remember hundreds of
movies and tv shows where the characters
do things like slip bugs they listen to
conversations with criminals and somehow
this all helps save the world through
eavesdropping your phone can really be
turned into a listening device but for
this you'll have to first of all install
several different special programs
you'll have to think with the settings
and well definitely disguise the
outgoing traffic as we mentioned but it
won't be possible to disguise all of
this within the regular day-to-day of
your smartphone activity and by the way
if you're using ios 14 or later on your
iphone pay attention to the colored dots
that appear in the upper right hand
corner of the screen the orange dot
indicates that some application is
currently using a microphone whereas the
green dot indicates that the camera is
working if you've downloaded some dodgy
app and you're on your home screen you
still see both of these dots then i
don't know maybe you should do some
cleaning let us know in the comments how
many pizza and dutch dessert ads you get
after watching this in any case my name
is bradley peake and this has been
another wholesome wrapped up worthwhile
walk around the wiggly westerly west
side of the online jungle i will see you
in the next video thanks for joining us
[Music]
you